if you have a question and maybe for
both of you a question on research for
historical novels now and I guess you've
been at it long enough to be done it
back pre-web and you have to wander
around Wales and stuff like that but
there's so much richness on the web I
was researching an historical period for
fiction changed over time you know I I
haven't really changed my methods at all
because the more information there is on
the web the more unreliable information
there is on the web so I usually will
between real libraries and what I can
find on Google sort of get a very very
superficial level of like hmm what is
there to look at but you either want to
go on site or try to go to closer to
preliminary sources you know print
primary sources to get the material I I
just yeah the more there is the less you
can trust of what there is well you
mentioned last night that when you were
working on fool's tale which is set in
medieval Wales you basically read
everything yes existed on that time and
place because there was a finite amount
there still is a finite amount but I bet
if you went on the web it would seem
like there was three or four times as
much
[Music]